- Hi, my name is Lisa Libicki,
I'm a School Programs
Educator here at MoMA.
This is Sol LeWitt's Wall Drawing #1144,
Broken Bands of Color in Four Directions.
Looking at this work, it's obviously
really eye-catching and visually dazzling,
and kids really get excited to see it
when we turn the corner.
They immediately notice the
four-panel construction.
Oftentimes they've studied
tessellations in class
and they'll say, "These
are four tessellations."
And then maybe that same
student and another student
will refine that observation and be like,
"Wait a second, these
aren't identical rectangles.
"They shift in scale and length."
I love immediately introducing the idea
that Sol LeWitt didn't paint this himself,
and I think students are really
sort of generally taken aback,
whether they're kindergartners
or twelfth graders.
And it's fun to watch that reaction.
Usually it immediately
generates questions,
like "How do they know what to do?
"Where was the connection between
the artist and the people?
"Was the artist here to watch them do it?"
I say that this drawing or painting
is based on a set of instructions
that usually comes along with a diagram,
and that's what the museum purchased,
or in this case actually was given.
I think oftentimes when students react,
"Wait a second, this is unfair,"
it oftentimes leads to the musicians
in the group that are
in their school's band
to be like, "Oh wait, someone
else composed this music,
"we all play it and let
the audience experience it,
"but we're not gonna claim
"that we wrote that Beethoven song.
"He gets the credit, and
he deserves the credit."
I often bring students here
as a last work in a tour
no matter what the theme might be,
because I feel like it
adds a new dimension
that usually hasn't been grappled with,
with any other object.
But sometimes I feel
like I like to end tours,
rather than tying everything together,
like, exploding everything,
and leave students like craving
more answers, more questions.